usar la energía nuclear para luchar
contra el dengue es la apuesta de un
grupo de biólogos argentinos en un
proyecto de esterilización para
mosquitos portadores de la enfermedad
esta prueba se realiza bajo la tutela de
la Comisión Nacional de energía atómica
con el objetivo de evitar la
reproducción masiva de mosquitos con
dengue se esterilizan mediante el uso de
energías ionizantes Y estos Machos
estériles son liberados al campo y al
encontrarse con una hembra salvaje La
descendencia producida no es viable y de
esta manera mediante liberaciones
sucesivas de estos Machos logramos
reducir la población de nuestro mosquito
vector según las autoridades se han
detectado
41.257 casos de dengue en territorio
argentino solo en lo que va de 2023 las
infecciones se concentran en 14 de las
24 jurisdicciones argentinas Buenos
Aires siendo una de las más afectadas
una consecuencia del cambio climático
este mosquito debido a esto al aumento
de las temperaturas generales que hay en
nuestro país y en el mundo porque no
solo en nuestro país lo que hace es
poder dispersarse más entonces cada vez
se corre más al sur su sus límites de
población antiguamente sus límites
llegaban hasta la provincia de Entre
Ríos luego en el 2006 ya se encontraron
muchos ejemplares en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires y en la actualidad más o menos se
cree que es la dispersión es hasta Bahía
Blanca cada año alrededor de 400
millones de personas se infectan con
Dengue en el mundo lo que convierte a
esta enfermedad en un factor de riesgo
para las poblaciones más vulnerables